ja schwieriger außenpolitische Fragen
die dazu beantworten sind und darüber
können wir jetzt sprechen mit dem
Bundeskanzler zugeschaltet aus Hiroshima
wegen der Zeitverschiebung schönen guten
Morgen Herr Bundeskanzler
guten Morgen Herr Bundeskanzler sie
haben praktisch während des Gipfels eine
Art verbale Protestnote schon von China
erhalten die sich auf die Gipfel
Erklärung bezieht darin beklagt Peking
die G7 Betrieben Blockbildung die Gruppe
müsse aufhören Konfrontation und
Spaltung zu verbreiten riskiert der
Westen hier die nächste Konfrontation
mit einer wirtschaftlich und militärisch
schlagkräftigen Diktatur
nein und das ist auch nicht
gerechtfertigt im Hinblick auf die
Gesprächsergebnisse die wir hier erzielt
haben es ist sehr klar gesagt worden
dass der wirtschaftliche Aufschwung
vieler Länder im Südamerikas in Afrika
und in Asien gewollt wird und das gilt
auch für China wir dürfen ja nicht
vergessen in viele Bürger und Bürger
Chinas Leben unverändert noch in sehr
prekären wirtschaftlichen Verhältnissen
und deshalb hat niemand an Interesse das
wirtschaftliche Wachstum zu behindern es
geht darum dass wir dafür sorgen dass es
nicht dazu kommt dass man abhängig wird
voneinander sondern die Welt
funktioniert dann gut wenn sie möglichst
breitflächig aufgestellt ist ein
Stichwort unter dem das hier formuliert
worden ist lautet deshalb die risking
also wir werden dafür Sorge tragen dass
es weiter große Investitionen gibt aus
den USA aus Japan aus Großbritannien aus
Frankreich Italien und Deutschland in
China das Lieferketten mit China
bestehen dass man dorthin waren verkauft
aber das ist eben auch für andere Länder
mögliches solche Dinge voranzutreiben
und wenn man drei Lieferanten oder zehn
hat ist die Welt eben ein Stück sicherer
sie sagen es möglichst breit aufgestellt
allerdings ist die Unterstützung die sie
da im globalen Süden suchen ja kein
Selbstläufer das sehen wir beim Ukraine
kriegt der appellieren die G7 schon sehr
lange und sehr deutlich und müssen
trotzdem dabei zuschauen dass knapp die
Hälfte der Weltbevölkerung Russland
nicht isolieren möchte sind sie da zum
zusehend
wichtig ist dass wir uns sehr klar
machen dass die Welt in der wir künftig
leben eine
multipolare wird mit sehr vielen auch
sehr starken Nationen die in den Ländern
im Süden Amerikas in Afrika und Asien
jetzt entstehen und sich
weiterentwickeln und das kann uns gut
gelingen wenn wir jetzt spätestens
anfangen auf Augenhöhe miteinander zu
sprechen dafür habe ich schon geworben
bei dem G7 Gipfel den wir in Deutschland
ausgerichtet haben und das ist sehr sehr
wertgeschätzt worden von den
eingeladenen Ländern dort aus diesen
Teilen der Welt und dann knüpfen wir
hier jetzt auch wieder an es ist richtig
dass es bei der Generalversammlung der
Vereinten Nationen so ist das nicht alle
Länder den Resolutionen zugestimmt haben
bei der Verurteilung des russischen
Angriffs aber ich weiß und das wissen
wir auch hier aus den Gesprächen fast
alle
von denjenigen die sich dort enthalten
haben oder nicht mit zugestimmt haben
und angewiesen nicht anwesend gewesen
sind wissen schon genau was los ist
Russland hat die Ukraine aus
machtgründen aus imperialistischen
machtgründen überfallen und das ist eine
Bedrohung für Sicherheit und Frieden und
das wollen wir jetzt auch als Grundlage
nehmen für die Gespräche die wir führen
und haben wir hier auch dafür genommen
sie beschreiben da die freundliche Seite
der Diplomatie aber gleichzeitig haben
die G7 mehr anscheinend auch den
Eindruck dass es etwas mehr Druck
braucht denn wenn man mal in die
Erklärung zur Ukraine reinschaut dann
steht da unter anderem eine Drohung an
Dritte Länder die nicht sofort aufhören
Russlands Aggression materiell zu
unterstützen heißt es da würden einen
erheblichen Preis zahlen wer und was ist
denn damit gemeint
wir haben Sanktionen verhängt und wir
wollen dass die nicht umgangen werden
und genau das ist das worauf wir auch
bestehen müssen übrigens gilt das auch
im Hinblick auf Waffen die Foren und
diese Botschaft ist sehr klar ist sie
überhaupt verstanden worden von vielen
Ländern in der Welt und deshalb sind die
Sanktionen die wir verhängt haben ja
auch viel weitreichender und
erfolgreicher als manche das vorher
gesagt haben Ukraine gibt es jetzt eine
neue Entwicklung was die Unterstützung
betrifft die USA wollen ukrainische
Piloten für Kampfjets ausbilden für F16
Flieger russland hat darauf schon
reagiert und meint westliche Länder
würden kolossale Risiken eingehen finden
Sie persönlich vor diesem Hintergrund
die geplante Kampfjet Koalition richtig
die USA und einige andere die über die
entsprechende Flugzeuge verfügen vor
allem haben jetzt ja gesagt dass sie
pilotenausbilden wollen das ist ein
Projekt das nicht von kurzer Dauer ist
das muss man sich immer klar sagen und
die Entscheidung ob und wann es
Zulieferung solcher Flugzeuge kommt die
wird erst zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt
getroffen so hat es ja der amerikanische
Präsident auch ausgedrückt klar ist dass
wir jetzt etwas tun müssen um die
Ukraine zu unterstützen das haben wir
aus Deutschland heraus zum Beispiel
gemacht indem wir jetzt noch mal ganz
neu gesagt haben welche weiteren
Lieferung von Munition von Waffen wir
auf den Weg bringen werden insbesondere
um die jetzt anstehenden
Vorhaben der Ukraine zu unterstützen die
eroberten Gebiete wieder frei zu
bekommen und das ist das was jetzt
unmittelbar ansteht jetzt sind sie
gerade in Südostasien unterwegs und
reisen heute noch weiter nach Südkorea
der Wald spielt sich hier in Berlin die
Lage in der Koalition zu und wenn ich
sie jetzt gerade hier im Gespräch habe
kann ich sie natürlich nicht ganz ohne
Frage dazu weglassen es geht um die
heizungspläne des Wirtschaftsministers
und um die Stimmung dazu in der
Koalition schauen wir mal kurz auf das
Thema
er hatte einen Plan er war für ihn
wichtig und jetzt ist Patrick reichen
weg von nun an geht es um Robert Habeck
vor allem aber geht es um den Plan
selbst das heizungsgesetz und damit das
Kernstück der Energiewende
klar war die Union will das so nicht DIE
LINKE will mehr Geld für sozialen
Ausgleich und die AFD ist komplett
dagegen soweit so normal jetzt aber wird
es kritisch für die Koalition in den
eigenen Reihen wächst der Unmut singt
die Unterstützung zuerst stellt die FDP
den Zeitplan in Frage und knüpft Ihre
Zustimmung an Änderungen nun scheint
auch bei den Sozialdemokraten die
Stimmung mehr und mehr zu bröckeln erst
kommt aus den Ländern kontra der
Generalsekretär sagt dann aber alles
werde eins zu eins wie geplant umgesetzt
doch plötzlich hört sich der
Fraktionschef ganz anders an man habe zu
einseitig auf die Wärmepumpe gesetzt und
ab wann die neuen Regeln gelten müssen
wir genau bedenken was gilt nun in der
Kanzlerpartei und was wird damit aus der
wärmewende der Ampel alles wieder
ungewiss und ein klares Bekenntnis des
Kanzlers was genau will die SPD das
steht bisher aus
zusammengefasst kann man sagen da sind
die Grünen die das Thema sehr schnell
noch vor der Sommerpause durchkriegen
wollen die FDP fordert eine komplette
Verschiebung des gebäudeenergiegesetzes
und Rolf Mütze nicht sagt ab wann die
neuen Regeln gelten das müssen wir sehen
was sagt denn der Bundeskanzler
die Regierung getragen von drei Parteien
hat ein Gesetz an den Deutschen
Bundestag geschickt das schon ganz
anders aussieht als das was viele noch
diskutieren weil ja die Debatte sich
festgemacht hat an einem Rohentwurf der
gar nicht fertig war und das Gesetz das
jetzt diskutiert wird hat schon viele
viele der Sorgen und Bedenken die viele
berechtigt geäußert haben aufgegriffen
jetzt wird das im Bundestag diskutiert
da gilt ja der Grundsatz eines früheren
SPD-Fraktionsvorsitzenden keinen Gesetz
kommt so aus dem Bundestag raus wie es
da reingegangen ist und das ist in der
Demokratie auch richtig ich glaube
allerdings dass es nicht dazu kommt dass
jetzt im Kern große Veränderung
vorgenommen werden aber es ist natürlich
völlig in Ordnung zu gucken sind alle
Fragen beantwortet sind alle Bedenken
berücksichtigt damit das so ist dass wir
die Ziele erreichen die wir erreichen
wollen wenn wir Klima neutral
Wirtschaften wollen in Deutschland aber
das ist gleichzeitig niemanden
überfordert und dass niemand für eine
unlösbare Aufgabe gestellt und das soll
jetzt und wird jetzt in jede Richtung
durchgesehen anhand des Gesetzes und das
ist ja auch etwas worauf die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger sich verlassen können ihr
Vizekanzler der sich um dieses Thema
nicht nur kümmern muss wenn sie weg sind
und unterwegs sind der wirkt momentan
politisch schwer angeschlagen hat Robert
Habeck noch das politische Gewicht für
diese schwierige Aufgabe
klar
kurze knappe Antwort herzlichen Dank für
das Gespräch
schönen Dank